[Music]
I was lost but now
I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi my name is Dan hey and I'm the
executive producer of Far Cry the brand
as well as the creative director of Far
Cry 5 I'd like to introduce you to hope
County Montana vast beautiful rugged a
place where people don't even lock their
front door anymore but that's how it
used to be today
Hope County's been overrun by a
fanatical cult you find yourself trapped
deep in cult territory cut off from the
rest of the world they closed the roads
there's no cell phone signal no 9-1-1
people are [ __ ] scared I had to say
and just up ahead the small town of
Falls End has been completely overrun if
you're going to survive you and your
guns for hire are gonna need to save it
but to do that well you're gonna need to
raise some hell
we got pegas Sam looks like a war zone
Wiki woman
water tower got
I'm in position
only bad will you walk in the light of
our Father let burn boom [ __ ]
[Music]
boom-boom-boom turn it up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you